hey you know who's getting quite famous
who
jd uh uh uh how so
tell tell robin what happened to you
what
uh i don't know what we're talking about
the
uh when i went to a restaurant a couple
weekends ago the
chef recognized me and uh uh
you know what do you mean you don't know
you know what happened
jamie what do you mean
he knows tell robin tell them about your
thing
free uh like appetizer thing or whatever
and
uh some drinks got comped and whatnot it
was very nice very appreciative very uh
very nice guy you didn't get some you
got pappy van winkle which is like a
hundred dollars a pour
happy van winkle yeah i was a i was
drinking
van winkle apparently i did i actually
don't remember it because i was blasted
out of my mind by that oh
god i didn't remember how i got home
look at you
yeah [ __ ] uh jd clooney
so you just made a reservation in this
restaurant right
well we actually walked in and uh
yes and then the guy i guess the guy
uh we tried to sit at the bar but uh
you know with their seats outside so we
sat out there and i guess a guy
recognized me or something and
uh yeah we got inside okay and then what
happened then it was like
oh mr j.d
i was with someone that orders
extravagance i was with a friend who
orders you know
he knows you should know that jd smoked
weed and had edibles at that dinner as
well
he's turned into a real maniac
i was a maniac yes or you really
embraced the weed community
i mean it was like how many years ago
two years ago you just started smoking
weed for the first time yeah
gummies i i do prefer gummies because i
don't like uh
smoke uh i don't like the feeling of
smoke like
no you don't like lighting the joint
because you don't know how to work a
lighter
well that too that too that's a little
troublesome sometimes
what i heard he's downplaying it they
set out a special table like he was
henry hill
taking this girl to the traffic camera
i'm trying i'm waiting to hear what he
tells you then i'm giving you the truth
i i by the end of the night my friend
had to
deal with things because i wasn't uh i
didn't know what was going on
to be quite honest can you imagine like
you go to
you know jd's barely coherent when he's
sober
right then you go out with him and he's
like
[Laughter]
like what joy is there in being with
pretty grumpy
that's jd's now hiring a glam team did
you know that
they got ways to go